protéger la Terre contre l’éventualité
d'un astéroïde menaçant c'est le buvisé
par le programme de protection
planétaire de la NASA
[Musique]
préparé que peuvent préparer la
Québécoise Julie Bellerose est la chef
de navigation de la mission dirt une
mission qui vise à tester un scénario de
défense ça c'est vraiment la première
mission dans le cadre de défendre la
planète des assurés des comètes des
petits coeurs qui pourraient venir vers
la terre après un voyage de neuf mois la
sonde devrait atteindre sa cible ce
lundi 26 septembre à 19h14 minutes heure
de l'Est
la sonde s'écrasera à une vitesse de
23600 km à l'heure sur un petit
astéroïde de 160 mètres appelé dimorphos
toute proportion gardée c'est comme si
on lançait une voiture aide de golf
contre la pyramide de Khéops
le but n'est pas de détruire la stéroïde
qui de toute façon ne présente aucune
menace pour nous on vise plutôt à le
dévier de son orbite
la NASA compte mener d'autres missions
du genre d'ici quelques années elle
dispose donc d'un corps beaucoup de
temps pour peaufiner son futur plante
sauvetage
c'est pas impossible mais en ce moment
c'est improbable
on estime à 99% les chances de succès de
la mission dirt toutefois on sera
seulement à la mi-octobre c'est
l'astéroïde a été dévie de son orbite
ici Dany Lemieux Radio-Canada Montréal